WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO END
THIS WAR?
, ARMORED FIGHTING VEHICLES,
AND MUCH, MUCH MORE AMMUNITION.
JOHN KIRBY OF THE U.S. NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL INSIST THAT
THE ALLIANCE IS STILL
ROCK-SOLID ALL ANDS FOR
UKRAINE'S DEFENSE.
>> JOHN KIRBY, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> THE BIG ISSUE FOR THE DAY IS
THE TANKS, THE TANKS, THE TANKS.
SO, FIRST AND FOREMOST, THE
UNITED STATES APPEARS NOT TO BE
WILLING TO SEND ITS AND ONE
TANKS TO UKRAINE.
WHY NOT?
>> WE ARE STILL WORKING OUR WAY
THROUGH A MYRIAD OF REQUESTS BY
THE UKRAINIANS FOR CAPABILITIES,
CHRISTIANE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE ARMORED
CAPABILITY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS A FIGHT IN THE
DONBAS AND GET READY TO FIGHT
IN COMING MONTHS OVER THE
SPRING.
WE EXPECT THERE'S QUITE BE
QUITE A BIT OF GROUND MANEUVER,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY, TANKS WOULD BE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF.
BUT WE MADE NO DECISIONS ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT OTHER NATIONS
ARE WILLING TO GIVE.
THE BRITS HAVE AGREED TO GET
SOME TANKS.
I KNOW THE GERMANS ARE TALKING
ABOUT AMONGST THEMSELVES.
THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY DECISIONS
THEY HAVE TO MAKE.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES AS WELL.
I WOULD TELL, YOU THE ABRAMS
TANK IS A VERY SOPHISTICATED
SYSTEM, IT REQUIRES A VERY
LENGTHY, DETAILED, COMPLICATED
SUPPLY CHAIN.
I'M NOT RULING ANYTHING IN A
ROW.
I'M JUST SAYING --
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE AS WE
PROVIDE UKRAINE --
CAPABILITY, IT'S A TYPE THEY
CAN USE.
AND THEY CAN USE KATE --
IN SHORT ORDER.
>> JOHN KIRBY, A LOT OF PEOPLE,
MILITARY EXPERTS, THINK THE
ABRAMS MAY NOT BE ANY GOOD,
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU
SAID.
IT'S A GAS GUZZLER, IT'S ALL OF
THAT.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS THE CASE?
THAT ACTUALLY IT'S NOT WHAT IS
NEEDED ON THE BATTLEFRONT RIGHT
NOW?
>> AGAIN, WE'RE STILL WORKING
OUR WAY THROUGH THAT.
I THINK --
IF YOU JUST TAKE A STEP BACK
FROM JUST THE ABRAMS ITSELF,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE KIND OF
ADVANCE CAPABILITIES WERE
GIVING UKRAINE, WE HAVE TO BE
MINDFUL THAT WE ARE NOT GIVING
THEM CAPABILITIES THAT THEY
CANNOT ABSORB READILY OR
EFFECTIVELY.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THEY'RE NOT
SMART, OR CAPABLE.
THEY, ARE WE'RE TRAINING THEM
ON MISSILE SYSTEMS RIGHT NOW IN
OKLAHOMA.
BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
THERE ABSORPTION RATE.
AND THE ABILITY TO USE THIS
MATERIAL IN SHORT ORDER, AND
VERY EFFECTIVELY AGAINST THE
ENEMY.
THE ABRAMS IS A VERY
SOPHISTICATED, CAPABLE TANK.
NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BUT, AGAIN AS WE WORK THROUGH,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING THIS IN A SMART WAY.
>> OKAY, SO THE PROBLEM IS, AND
YOU MENTIONED ALLIES.
IT APPEARS THAT, LET'S SAY,
GERMANY, WHICH HAS THE TANK
VIGIL, THE LEOPARD 2, WHICH IT
SEEMS EVERYONE IS FOCUSING ON.
THE UKRAINIANS WON, IT'S MUCH
MORE FLEXIBLE THAN THE ABRAMS.
IT'S APPARENTLY MUCH MORE
SUITED FOR THAT BATTLEFIELD.
AND YET, IT APPEARS THE GERMANS
DON'T WANT TO BE THE FIRST TO
SEND A TANK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE ACCUSED
OF A GERMAN-LED ESCALATION.
SO, IS THIS GETTING DOWN TO, I
DON'T EVEN KNOW TO SAY.
BUT THE GERMANS IN THE POLLS --
THE POLLS ARE SAYING, THIS IS
JUST WASTING TIME.
SOMEONE'S AND THE TANKS
ALREADY.
>> THE BRITS HAVE ALREADY
AGREED TO SEND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGER TANKS, WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY VERY, VERY WELCOME.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE --
AND WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION LAST
WEEK.
TANKS WERE CERTAINLY ON THE
AGENDA.
BUT YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
RESULTS OF THAT MEETING IN
GERMANY HOW MANY DOZENS OF
NATIONS ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT UKRAINE WITH
SOPHISTICATED WEAPONS SYSTEMS
ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER, IS THESE ARE NATIONAL
DECISIONS.
THEY ARE SOVEREIGN DECISIONS.
I CERTAINLY CANNOT SPEAK FOR
THE GERMANS OR WHAT IS GOING
INTO THEIR CALCULUS ABOUT THE
LEOPARD TANKS.
BUT LEOPARDS ARE VERY GOOD.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF THEM ON
THE EUROPEAN CONTINENT.
AND CERTAINLY, THEY COULD BE
EFFECTIVE ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
BUT, AGAIN --
THEY HAVE TO WORK THROUGH THIS
IN A SOVEREIGN WAY.
THAT'S BEEN OUR APPROACH SINCE
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
WE WANT NATIONS TO CONTRIBUTE
WHAT THEY CAN WHEN THEY CAN, ON
THE SCALE IF THEY CAN.
BUT WE ARE NOT TWISTING ARMS.
WE'RE NOT FORCING PEOPLE TO
GIVE MORE THAN THEY ARE WILLING
TO GIVE.
EACH COMPANY COUNTRY HAS
NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST TO
PUT HIS --
CONCERT ON THEIR OWN.
>> BUT YOU SEE THE THING IS,
FOR THE LAST NEARLY A YEAR
YOU'VE ALL SAID THIS IS OUR
JOINT NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE, OUR
EXISTENTIAL MISSION IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT UKRAINE WINS AND
PUTIN IS DEFEATED.
THAT'S BEEN YOUR MANTRA
THROUGHOUT.
AND NOW, WE'VE GOT WOULD APPEAR
TO BE, ANYWAY, OR BEING
DESCRIBED AS, INCLUDING BY THE
KREMLIN SPOKESMAN, A DIVISION
BETWEEN NATO ALLIES AND A
DIVISION BETWEEN NATO AND
UKRAINE.
THIS IS PLAYING RIGHT INTO
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S HANDS.
>> I WOULD TAKE WHATEVER MR.
PESKOV SAYS WITH A HUGE GRAIN
OF SALT.
NATO HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
STAUNCHLY UNITED THAN IT HAS
BEEN OVER THE LAST YEAR WITH
THIS WAR IN UKRAINE.
AND OUR LOOKING AT GROWING THE
ALLIANCE BY TWO OTHER NATIONS.
BECAUSE OF WHAT MR. PUTIN HAS
DONE THERE.
IT'S A LOT OF COUNTRIES IN THE
ALLIANCE.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO EVER
AGREE ON EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF
EVERY DECISION REALIZED MAKES.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE ALLIANCE
SO STRONG.
THEIR FRIENDS, ALLIES AND
PARTNERS COULD HAVE HONEST
DISCUSSIONS WITH ONE ANOTHER.
BUT TO SAY THIS IS DIVIDING THE
ALLIANCE ARE SOMEHOW PUTTING
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK
IN UKRAINE BECAUSE THERE'S A
DISCUSSION OVER TANKS IS JUST
WAY OVER BLOWING THIS THING.
>> SO AS YOU KNOW, POLAND HAS
SAID AND OTHERS HAVE SAID THAT
THEY WANT TO SEND THEIR GERMAN
MADE LEOPARD TANKS IF THEY CAN
GET A SMALL COALITION OF THE
WILLING TO DO THAT.
THE GERMAN MEN FOREIGN MINISTER
SAID HER COUNTRY WILL NOT STAND
IN THE WAY OF OTHER COUNTRIES
DOING THAT SHOULD THEY WANT TO.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON
STRATEGY?
LET'S PUT ASIDE THE WEAPONS,
ALTHOUGH IT'S PART OF IT.
BUT CLEARLY, THE BRITS AND YOU
SAW THE BRITISH FOREIGN
MINISTER IN WASHINGTON RECENTLY
SAY, NOW IS THE TIME.
WE BELIEVE, IF THEY GET ALL THE
WEAPONS THEY NEED --
THAT THIS WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY
IS A TIME TO ARM THE MOB.
AND BE ABLE TO SCORE A VICTORY
THIS YEAR.
BUT, YOUR CHAIRMAN OF JOINT
CHIEFS, MARK MILLEY SAYS, NO,
NOT THIS YEAR.
WHAT IS?
IT IS THE UNITED STATES TRYING
TO DRAG THIS OUT?
TRYING TO WEAKEN THE RUSSIANS?
DOES THE UNITED STATES NOT
THINK THAT YOU CAN SCORE A
VICTORY?
WHAT IS THE STRATEGIC
DIFFERENCE THERE?
>> WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SEE
THIS WAR AND.
TODAY COULD IF PUTIN PULLS THE
TROOPS OUT, IT'S NOT GONNA,
HAPPEN I RECOGNIZE THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS DRAG
ON ONE SINGLE DAY THAN TODAY.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT UKRAINE CAN
SUCCEED ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
SO THAT IF AND WHEN MR.
ZELENSKYY IS READY TO GO TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE, WHATEVER
THAT MIGHT, BE THEY CAN DO THAT
WITH STRENGTH AND HAND.
HE HAS SUCCESS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD BEHIND HIM, AND
WIND IN HIS BACK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON.
AND EVERY NATION INSIDE THIS
COALITION OF THE WILLING AS WE
MIGHT CALL, IT IS PROVIDING
CAPABILITY.
SOMETIMES IT JUST FINANCES.
AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
TO HELP UKRAINE GET INTO A
BETTER POSITION.
THE STRATEGY ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
THAT HAS TO BE UP TO MR.
ZELENSKYY AND HIS MILITARY
LEADERS.
HE'S THE ONE THAT'S GOING TO
DETERMINE WHERE THEY ARE GOING
TO STRIKE, WHEN THEY ARE GOING
TO STRIKE, AND WHAT FORCE.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS IN
ADVANCE OF THOSE OPERATIONS,
AND WE EXPECT THE FIGHTING IS
GOING TO CONTINUE THROUGHOUT
THE WINNER, IT'S BEEN A VIOLENT
WINTER THROUGHOUT THE DONBAS,
AND INTO THE SPRING.
IN ADVANCE OF THOSE DECISIONS,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE IN LOCKSTEP WITH MR.
ZELENSKYY AND HIS MILITARY
LEADERS ABOUT THE CAPABILITY HE
NEEDS TO GET THEIR.
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE
BATTALION TRAINING THAT WE'RE
DOING OUTSIDE OF UKRAINE AT A
BATTALION LEVEL.
FOR UKRAINIAN BATTALIONS ON
WHAT WE CALL COMBINE ARMS
OPERATIONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DONBAS A LOT
OF OPEN FARMLAND, OPEN TERRAIN.
THAT IS WHAT MR. ZELENSKYY AND
HIS MILITARY LEADERS FEEL THEY
NEED TO IMPROVE.
THEIR COMBINED ARMS OPERATION
IN THAT PART OF THE COUNTRY.
GOING INTO THE SPRING.
AND SO WE'RE DOING THAT
TRAINING OUTSIDE OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE UNITED
STATES.
THERE'S OTHER NATIONS INVOLVED.
AND A LOT OF THE VEHICLES THAT
YOU'VE SEEN US, GIVEN JUST THE
LAST TWO WEEKS --
THE STRIKER, COMBAT VEHICLES,
THE M WRAPS, FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
THOSE MINE RESISTANT, ARMOR
PROTECTIVE VEHICLES.
ALL OF THOSE ARE GOING TO HELP
WITH THE UKRAINIAN FORCES IN
THE FIELD, IN THE DONBAS, IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
WE'RE VERY MUCH TRYING TO STAY
AHEAD OF THE FIGHT AS MR.
ZELENSKYY SEIZED IT.
SHOTS DOES NOT CAN YOU TAKE A
BACK INTO THE OR GOVERNMENT MY
QUESTION IS, DO YOU SEE MANY
STRATEGIST THAT THERE IS A
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY NOW TO
EXPLOIT RUSSIA'S APPARENT
WEAKNESS, ITS INABILITY TO
REALLY DOUBLE DOWN AND TAKE SO
MUCH TERRITORY.
BEFORE, YOU ALL SAID, THEY ARE
REGROUPING FOR A MASSIVE
OFFENSIVE IN THE SPRING.
>> WE ARE ALL MINDFUL OF THE
TIME COMPONENT HERE, CHRISTIANE,
AND WE KNOW THAT TIME IS NOT
OUR FRIEND, AND THAT IS NOT THE
FRIEND OF UKRAINE.
WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY WINTER RIGHT
NOW, WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE NOT
IDEAL FOR FIGHTING, AND YET
FIGHTING CONTINUES IN THE AIR
AND ON THE GROUND.
WE HAVE MR. PUTIN CONTINUING TO
STRIKE CIVILIAN TARGETS WITH
CRUISE MISSILES AND DRONES,
COMING IN FROM IRAN, AND WE
KNOW, AS YOU RIGHTLY POINTED
OUT, THAT HE IS REGROUPING AND
PREPARING HIMSELF FOR MORE
AGGRESSIVE OPERATIONS TO COME
IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS,
PROBABLY IN THE SPRING WHEN THE
WEATHER GETS BETTER.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE ARE AT A
CRITICAL POINT, AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS CALLED THIS
INFLECTION POINT.
AND SO THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING SO MUCH ENERGY BEING PUT
IN BY THE ALLIES TO GET UKRAINE
THE KIND OF CAPABILITIES THAT
THEY NEED FOR THESE COMBINED
ARE MANEUVERS, OPERATIONS, THAT
WE THINK THEY WILL BE
CONDUCTING PROBABLY IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS.
OBVIOUSLY, WE ARE MINDFUL OF
THAT, AND THAT IS WHY YOU'VE
SEEN TO REALLY BEGIN SECURITY
ASSISTANCE PACKAGES FROM THE
UNITED STATES ALONE IN JUST THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
OTHER NATIONS ARE STEPPING UP
AS WELL.